every company owned Starbucks outlet in
the US will close for a short time this
afternoon four hours after an incident
that shook the coffee powerhouse you've
likely seen this video many many times
he arrested two black men in April
inside a philadelphia Starbucks Dante
Robinson and Rashad Nelson were placed
in handcuffs after a store manager
called the police they had not bought
anything yet when they asked to use a
restroom well today's closure is part of
the company's racial bias training and
first on CBS this morning
we welcome Starbucks executive chairman
Howard Schultz back to studio 57 he
joins us at the table Howard good to
have you here thank you let's say we
were with you in Philadelphia the next
day after that incident and you told us
you were embarrassed in a shame and I
was telling people I thought your pain
was palpable I'm wondering how you're
feeling today you've been through the
training and how you're feeling about
how Starbucks has handled the situation
what you hope will come out of this
training today well I think as I share
with you in Philadelphia it was a
reprehensible situation that we took
complete ownership of and something that
really was embarrassing horrifying and
all the issues that we talked about that
day since that time I think we have
decided that we need to use this as an
opportunity to really transform the
training and the opportunity to share
with our Starbucks partners 175,000
people everything that we possibly can
with experts who could co-author with us
a legitimate way to provide racial bias
training to demonstrate that we all have
unconscious bias and I think we're
living at a time in America where there
is a fracturing of humanity and we have
an opportunity given the fact that we
have stores in every community in
America to begin a very important
conversation we've been in business for
almost 50 years this is probably one of
the most important transformational
moments in the history of our company
and we've taken it very seriously what
is racial bias training well I think
most importantly it's to try and provide
the reference in the tools
for people to understand that we all
have had a life experience and add that
life experience has provided us with a
level of understanding that may be
different than the level of
understanding you have it doesn't have
to be about race it could be about
ethnic background sexual orientation
your station and life but it's all about
prank trying to provide a level of
empathy and compassion and new level of
sensitivity and given the fact that
Starbucks is this third place in America
we want to be a welcoming environment to
everybody regardless of their position
but that's saying a man convinces gets
tears will is still of the same opinion
still I'm wondering what do you intend
for people to learn in four hours
because some people say look Howard
sounds really great but sounds like a
marketing ploy to me well first up I
don't know if there's any company in
America that's ever taken on something
at this level it's interesting to me for
us to be criticized for doing it for
four hours it's just the beginning what
we've said to our board to our
shareholders is that we are deeply
committed to me to making this part of
everything we do we hire a hundred
thousand new people a year this is going
to be part of the onboarding training
we're gonna globalize this I've been
through the training myself as as has
all the global leaders and this is
something that we're gonna stay with not
something that's going to be a marketing
or PR we could have spent marketing
dollars a lot different than something
like this let me ask you about what else
you could be doing Starbucks has
promised to open a store in Anacostia in
Washington DC where it does not
currently have one one of the poorest
areas in the district and I was talking
to an official from DC who said by
implicit bias training is nice but more
stores in communities of color showing
that you put your money where your mouth
is would help a lot more in showing a
message from the company into America so
you're gonna do more of that more
investment more opening up stores in
places where you normally wouldn't see
us not only are we gonna do more of that
but we've opened stores in Ferguson in
Bedford Stuyvesant and Inglewood in
Oakland throughout America where
traditionally a brand like Starbucks is
not located and we've done this so that
we can be a beacon of hope for the
community we can demonstrate that it's
good business other companies can follow
us in we're hiring kids we've hired a
hundred
thousand opportunity youth kids in the
last couple of years these are children
who are ages 18 to 24 mostly kids of
color who did not have jobs and local
vendors so already doing these things
let me ask you what your partners say to
you because they say wait a minute I'm
not reprehensible if I'm just trying to
manage a very difficult situation in a
culture here in my store why am i
reprehensible what have you heard from
them yes as they engage in this training
I think it's very important to say there
was never any blame on any one person I
went to Philadelphia immediately and we
stood up as leaders of the company and
said the company and the leadership of
Starbucks are responsible we did not
blame anybody we said the act was
reprehensible and that we needed to
transform our training this is about
leadership and this is about moral
courage and standing up and being
accountable and I think what we're doing
today is not only have I not seen any
company do anything like this this takes
a lot of courage and as a public company
we're under criticism from our
shareholders saying this is make money
here other companies do this I can't
speak for other companies but what I've
said to Cheryl is is this is not an
expense this is an investment in our
people and in our way of life in our
culture and our values
do you know Howard somebody is always
going to be a critic out there but I
think your company deserves a lot of
credit for trying to tackle this in a
way that no one has what has your
conversation like been with the two men
Dante Robinson and rashon Nelson have
you spoken with them recently
interestingly enough they were in
Seattle on Friday where we spent the
entire day with them these are two fine
young men we apologize to them countless
times and what we're doing for them and
with them is trying to do everything we
can to help them in their own careers
since we offer free college tuition for
all Starbucks employees we're giving
them them that that benefit as well
people want to know where they
compensated
they were compensated and and obviously
we can't release that but Starbucks has
done a lot to try and make this right as
much as we can we hope you we hope
you'll come back and update it release
it Howard
Yeah right listen as you as you leave us
you'll be heading to the green room
senator Elizabeth Warren is there some
people could say we're looking at two
top contenders for the Democratic Party
what do you say I think
legal is one great candidate okay so you
can say hello is it will he's going by
thank you for joining us hope you'll
come back and update us thank you very
much thank you